welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos here with my buddy and fellow star
wars obsessive Danny Paquette ski hey
guys
star wars episode 9 the rise of
Skywalker just released a final trailer
that made us feel every emotion all at
once oh yeah we are what a mess and
after breaking down the trailer
shot-by-shot we realized most of our
curiosities were coming from just two
seconds of trailer footage
no not Threepio yanking his own brains
out or Rey facing Mecca Palpatine or
whatever form is in there no this shot
Rey and kylo in a white tinted room
their lightsabers shattering a statue
kylo has his broken mask fused back
together Rey is holding a mysterious
dagger and there are even more clues
that keep popping up in the shot the
harder you look at it yeah Danny and I
are convinced that these 58 or so frames
shed more light on the still very
secretive plot of the rise of Skywalker
more than any other footage JJ Abrams
has been willing to show us we are gonna
dive back into the trailer in this
episode of explain whatever warning in
case we speculate too accurately on what
might actually be in this movie's plot
and thanks to privacy comm for
sponsoring this episode
if you go to privacy calm slash to new
rock stars you can get $5 today to use
on any purchase online for free ok this
setting is unlike any other location
we've seen in the rise of Skywalker
footage or any location we've seen in
the force awakens or the last Jedi
it contains the lined and dotted
lighting patterns that we've seen on the
Death Star and the second Death Star in
the original trilogy yeah the truth is
always in the fixtures and we have
gotten confirmation from the good folks
that the Star Wars show at Lucasfilm
that this location is quote kylos
Vader's shrine now the thing that they
shatter has one large piece that stays
intact as it falls you can see the
curved edge of the charred Vader mask
that kylo was revealed to possess in the
force awakens but question our Rey and
kylo intentionally collaborating to code
destroy this shrine or are they dueling
in their blades swing out of control and
accidentally caused this collateral
damage
yeah notice to the far right of the
frame there's a bunch of debris on the
ground from some other mess that was
happening so they're either going down
the line to deliberately break each item
down like they're tearing down a wall in
Extreme Makeover Home Edition move that
bot or their fight is kind of like
Grenada and big little lies smashing
their husbands
boys the biggest detail is the dagger
that Rey holds Erick speculated in his
breakdown that this could be the dagger
of mortis from the Star Wars animated
series but what is that thing exactly
okay yeah the dagger of mortis was
introduced in the mortis trilogy of Star
Wars the Clone Wars
obi-wan Anakin and ahsoka tano
encountered three cosmic beings with
godlike powers named the Father the Son
and the daughter now the Sun represents
the dark side of the force
the daughter represents the light side
of the force the father keeps him in
balance but he seeks the prophecy a
chosen one Anakin Skywalker to maintain
the balance after he's gone but Anakin
refuses the daughter takes w-wanted to
the altar of mortis to retrieve the
dagger the only thing that can kill the
son
ultimately the son uses a dagger to
attack the father who kills the daughter
by accident the father stabbed himself
with a dagger all three beings in the
bed many believe this is what tipped the
cosmic scales into chaos allowing later
on the Emperor and Vader to take over in
Revenge of the Sith but that is a lot of
lore from the animated series that
live-action movie goers will be expected
to understand yeah two words for you
Darth wall but you know you are right
it's all canon but it's a big jump from
the animated to live-action worlds and
that's why I think if raised dagger is
revealed to be the dagger mortise the
backstory of the father daughter and son
might only be implied in the thematic
way like there are definitely parallels
there with Rey as the daughter
kylo as the son and maybe Luke as the
father trying to maintain the balance
damn I mean that's deep I did not expect
the animated series to matter this much
I think I need to take a little bit of
time to notice okay you do that Danny
it'll give me a second to say thank you
to privacy comm for sponsoring this
episode privacy calm is a free service
that lets you buy things online using
virtual cards instead of your real
credit card info that way you'll be
completely covered it's essentially a
digital burner card with limits say you
control it's great like when you have to
scour the internet for a replica of the
dagger more to say you definitely need
to have and if you don't really really
trust the vendor they buying it from you
can just use one of privacy's burner
cards also privacy comm lets you avoid
having to give full access to your
personal finances every time you sign up
for a subscription because you know
those content subscribers are just
waiting for the 16th of the month to
pass or whatever and thing
here's another month of content that you
didn't want sucker so for example I have
set up an account with privacy
linked my bank account and I created a
card specifically for my monthly Netflix
subscription payment for this virtual
card I'm setting the limit just above my
monthly subscription amount so that way
if someone tries to use his privacy card
number again or like over target privacy
will block it because the spending limit
was already maxed out and they'll let
you know that they did it see it's
simple it's fast it's really just one
click and it's so easy and again it is
free and that's a special deal for you
guys first time customers who sign up
with privacy com slash new rock stars
will get five dollars off their first
purchase with privacy com just go to
privacy icon slash new rock stars it's
priv Acy comm slash any WRs ck st ARS to
get five dollars off your first purchase
now okay
I'm back and I've put some thought on
how this could relate to what Ray and
kylo are doing together first where are
they based on the evidence we've seen
this Vader shrine is likely some room or
vault in the ruins of the second Death
Star that kylo established and we know
that these ruins are not located on
Endor they're located on a new oceanic
moon called kev beer according to the
Disney Star Tours right yeah and based
on trailer footage it doesn't seem my
gray will be alone in her exploration of
these ruins spin appears on that trench
wall as well and if you look even more
closely at that room behind them that
looks like Chewbacca's BOE caster and
bandolier on the shelf
why would Chewie part ways with those
like did he offer them to Rey to help
her is he in the other room taking a
dump I I had a bad feeling about this so
it seems like part of the movie will
feature the main characters venturing to
catch beer to explore the ruins of the
second Death Star and while their race
stumbles into kylo Ren and the shrine
they to be assembled inside these ruins
they shatter a number of artifacts that
kylo had collected like Vader's Burt
mask but also artifacts that Palpatine
spirit might have possessed according to
the Star Wars lore past dark figures
like darth nihilus and momen possessed
objects and since Sidious was the
apprentice of Darth Plagueis the wise it
is possible that Sidious knows all kinds
of unnatural ways to circumvent death
one of the haunted objects could be this
dagger which may or may not be connected
to the dagger of mortis perhaps the
dagger when tampered with awakens the
spirit of Palpatine triggering his rise
in a long-forgotten element of his
infamous contingency plan operation
cinder
that's the plan from the shattered
Empire books in Battlefront 2 in which
Palpatine left behind pre-recorded
orders to devastate various planets in
the event of his death the old-school
Star Destroyers hidden under the ice
rising in trailer footage each featuring
a new super cannon they could all be
part of that operation and it all could
have started right here inside kylos
weird mancave what is your theory for
what is going on in this seat comment
down below with your thoughts and thank
you for joining me Danny it's nice to
have someone who loves Star Wars as much
as I do to tag-team these weird
explanations with having a boss and
thanks for keeping track of all the
animated series cannon because with
mauls return apparently it's all
required reading follow us on social
media and help us be able to do these
classic breakdown to the Star Wars
original trilogy and prequel trilogy in
the weeks leading up to the rise of
Skywalker the only way we can pull that
off is with the help of patron so please
consider becoming to patreon a new
rockstars Digital Studios just by
clicking the link in the description
below thanks for watching and if chewy
is dropping a load I sincerely hope he
flushes
yeah you don't want to smell that
Wookiee Dookie
[Music]